[Music]
mary's with us in spokane washington hi
mary welcome to the ramsey show
thank you how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
so i am 33 and i am making plans to
leave a abusive marriage um i have two
kids
um but i'm really scared and kind of
questioning what i need
moving forward
i've used your model in the past
we are debt-free but i do have a few
questions on
when i'm a single income home where do i
need to be placing certain things
i'm sorry
so do you have an income now
i do yes
okay how much do you make
110.
okay
um
why are you still there
you should leave today
um
i grew up with a single mom and i don't
care don't get a lot of trouble you said
abusive
and once you said abusive you're done
i know
you make a hundred and ten thousand
dollars a year you're gonna be fine i'll
help you we're gonna work with you but
honey you gotta get out of there you're
saying physical abuse right
yeah
there's a couple things um but he's
gotten treatment i don't care
you've made the decision to leave the
only thing holding you is
stockholm
syndrome i just don't know if i can do
it by myself
that's his that's his words not yours
his words in your head
it's what abusers do they take away your
confidence honey you make a hundred ten
thousand dollars a year there's a lot of
things you are but stupid ain't one of
them
stupid people don't make 110 a year
what do you do for a living
i work for the government um and i'm a
program manager okay all right
so you have a steady income and a great
income
yes why don't you think you can do it on
110 000 a year in spokane washington
um i just i
haven't made the jump yet and i don't
know whether or not i should buy or rent
a home with the current market you need
a rent
okay because you need to get out of
there this week
you don't have time to buy a home
okay you need to have a sense of urgency
that you don't have now
for the safety of your neck and your
kids
am i wrong
um i'm i feel like we are
safe and
why
um
there's certain things that he can't do
now because of
a charge that he's got and it's um he's
in counseling we're in counseling kids
are in counseling
so um
i'm just what keeps him from doing those
things a rule
a law yeah
a rule yeah
well there's a rule that happened long
before that rule was put in place the
rule is you don't hit your wife and your
kids that's a rule
that one didn't occur to him this guy
doesn't follow rules
okay
if
if you think that the domestic abuse is
over and that the counseling is working
you wouldn't be calling me
yeah i just i want to figure out how
financially best to
because like i said
okay let me restate that and you you
tell me if i'm right if you thought that
he was go that he was done
and he was getting well and he was
repentant and he was healing from
whatever it is that caused him to do
these things
if you thought that was the case you
wouldn't be calling me asking me how you
were going to end your marriage due to
the fact it was abusive so you don't
think he's better
you don't think he's okay you don't
think he's safe that's why you're
leaving am i missing something
no i just i've lost trust so although
things aren't occurring now i've lost
that trust and um
i don't want my kids to be further
traumatized and i don't want
them thinking that this is a healthy
relationship right how healthy
relationships should so you're so you're
done
yeah okay there's no reason for you to
stay a minute more mary
what specifically are you afraid of
dave's already told you and he's right
you've got a great income and a great
job what are you scared of because you
called and said i'm preparing to leave
but just like you're needing that nudge
i thought you were gonna tell me you
didn't have a job or something what are
you afraid of specifically
well
ptsd and anxiety doesn't help but i'm
i'm afraid that um
i'm not going to be enough for the kids
or that my income is not going to be
enough for them and
i don't know
if i'm how old are you
33 okay
and what's your degree in
uh nursing bachelor's nursing okay
all right
so
i want you to listen listen i i've got
i've got seven grandbabies
and a daughter your age
okay
and that's the only thing that
authorizes me to say this
so i don't i don't have a i don't have a
uh a doctoral
in counseling like dr john deloney i
don't have any of that but i want you to
listen to me real clearly okay
you
are going to be
an incredible
mother
because you're protecting your children
you are an intelligent lady you're a
smart lady you're a wise lady and you
make a ton of money
you're gonna be just fine
quit believing the lies that he has told
you that's the trap he put you in
okay you're gonna be fine the kids are
gonna be great
you're gonna do just fine
and they're gonna tell the story
sometime about their courageous mom who
got them away from an abusive dad
but you have to do this and you have to
do it right now
so here's what we're gonna do
okay because this is not a financial
problem this is an emotional
psychological problem
i am telling you as the the number one
guy in america to advise you on your
money that you have enough money to
leave and you should leave now
and you're you can feed your kids in
spokane washington on 110 000
you are fine
they are fine
you are enough you're going to be a
great mom you're going to be a great
single mom you're going to do great your
kids are going to heal you're going to
heal you're going to look in the
rearview mirror and see this manure in
the rearview mirror but you've got to
put it in the view mirror you're plenty
now here's what we're going to do i have
trained
ramsey certified coaches
in your market and kelly is going to
pick up and we're going to have you sit
down with one today or tomorrow it's
going to cost you nothing we're going to
pay for it
okay
okay and they're going to help you do a
budget and show you how to get your rent
going and show you how to get this stuff
done and i'm going to put you through
financial peace university so you could
be confident on handling money as well
now when you get that level of
confidence in the next three days
i want you to pack your stuff and get
out of there i'm scared for your babies
i'm scared you're gonna hang on and hang
on and hang on and hang on and hang on
because of your lack of confidence that
is completely unfounded and unfactual
does that sound mean
does that sound mean
okay
it's just um
embarrassing it's not embarrassing you
didn't do anything wrong
it is embarrassing but you didn't do it
okay
and i want you to hear loud and clear
that you're plenty you're enough
and i want you to feel a ramsay hug
coming through the airwaves right now
and this whole
is organization's to come around you and
make your life okay we're going to show
you how to do it you have the tools to
have a great life
okay thank you we believe in you i want
you to call me back on the air and tell
america that you're okay when you get
the crap out of that house
you hold on and kelly will pick up
and we're gonna get you signed up for
whatever you need
and uh hook her up with ken too but
she'll be hooked up a kitchen oh she's
crushing she's crushing it what am i
saying put her in everything she needs
anything she needs get it to her get her
out of the house kelly this is the
ramsay show